la séance est reprise en application du
cinquième alinéaire de l'article 13 de
la Constitution ainsi que de la loi
organique et de la ordinaire du 23
juillet 2010 prise pour son application
la Commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable a
émis lors de sa réunion du mercredi de
novembre 2022 un avis favorable 22 voies
pour aucune voix contre à la nomination
de Monsieur Stanislas Bourron aux
fonctions du directeur général de
l'Agence nationale de collision de
territoire l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion du projet de loi de finance
rectificative adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale pour 2022 et dans la
discussion générale la parole est à
Monsieur Gabriel Attal ministre délégué
chargé des comptes publics
autant jouer devant des âges dans des
ailes
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général du budget
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices et
c'est sénateurs depuis l'automne 2021
notre pays fait face à une inflation que
nous n'avions pas connu depuis des
décennies à la faveur de la reprise de
l'économie mondiale et depuis février
2022 de l'invasion de l'Ukraine la vie
chère met notre société à rue des
preuves disons-le sans détour la
situation est particulièrement difficile
et l'enlisement du conflit nous place
dans une situation de grande incertitude
les missiles tombaient hier soir sur le
sol polonais nous l'ont encore rappelé
oui le contexte est sombre mais notre
choix est clair ce choix c'est de lutter
contre la vie chère pour protéger les
Français et ce projet de loi de finance
rectificative marque une nouvelle étape
dans ce combat
c'est un combat que nous continuerons à
mener l'année prochaine car l'inflation
devrait demeurer un niveau important
mais nous devrons le mener de façon
différente je veux bien sûr parler d'une
approche plus ciblée dans les soutiens
que nous apporterons car l'équation des
finances publiques d'aujourd'hui ne
ressemble pas à celle que nous
connaissions durant cette parenthèse où
l'argent l'emprunt semblait gratuit ce
projet de loi de finance rectificatif
qui n'est pas seulement un texte de fin
de gestion s'inscrit dans la continuité
du paquet pouvoir d'achat que vous avez
voté et enrichi cet été je vous le dis
clairement c'est une continuité que je
revendique je la revendique parce
qu'elle constitue une réponse à
l'urgence et non compatriotes ne
comprendraient pas qu'on les laisse
démuni face au prix qui augmente je la
revendique aussi parce qu'elle a produit
des résultats la France est le pays de
la zone euro ou l'inflation demeure la
plus contenue
avant de vous présenter les grandes
lignes de ce texte il me semble utile de
vous dire un mot sur la situation de
l'économie française en cette fin
d'année 2022 vous le savez les
prévisions adossées à ce deuxième projet
de loi de finance rectificatif font état
d'une croissance de 2,7% cette année un
chiffre jugé crédible par le Haut
Conseil des finances publiques pour ma
part au delà des prévisions ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de savoir si nous
mettons tout en oeuvre pour atteindre
notre objectif il est évidemment trop
tôt pour dire avec une absolue certitude
si nous y parviendrons mais ce qui me
semble incontestable c'est que le texte
que nous vous présentons aujourd'hui
intensifie notre combat contre la vie
chère et permet donc à l'économie
française de mieux tenir le choc
c'est vrai les nuages s'amoncellent il y
a le conflit ukrainien que j'évoquais il
y a un instant on peut citer également
la crise immobilière en Chine le
l'inflation Redemption actes américains
constituent une forme de dumping aussi
et donc un enjeu et une difficulté et
des risques pour notre industrie et
notre économie en Europe le risque sur
la zone euro liée au choix qui seront
fait en Italie sur la trajectoire des
finances publiques tout cela constitue
des risques mais ce que l'on peut dire
et ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
notre économie résiste admirablement en
cette fin d'année 2022 il ne s'agit pas
de dire que tout va bien ou de verser
dans l'auto-satisfaite mais simplement
de savoir distinguer les signes
encourageants malgré l'incertitude
la réalité c'est que nous sommes au
coeur de la tempête mais cette tempête
ne nous emportera pas non elle ne nous
emportera pas car nous pouvons compter
sur des fondamentaux solides je souhaite
à cet égard rendre hommage à ces
millions de Françaises et de Français
qui se lèvent chaque matin pour créer de
la richesse par leur travail leur
courage leur audace leur intelligence à
tous les chefs d'entreprises qui
tiennent bon malgré les incertitudes et
les aléas à tous les élus à tous les
maires de notre pays qui tiennent bon là
aussi malgré les aléas malgré les
difficultés et malgré les inquiétudes à
tout cela qui tiennent bon malgré les
aléas la hausse des factures à ces
entrepreneurs qui continuent d'investir
d'embaucher d'inventer bref ce que je
veux saluer c'est cette France qui
résiste et qui ne cède pas un pouce de
terrain à la morosité
il faut relever à ce titre que nous
avons dans les derniers chiffres de
l'Insee des signes encourageants qui
démontrent la résilience de notre
économie la demande intérieure a
continué à soutenir la croissance et ce
malgré une hausse des prix que nous
n'avions pas connu depuis des décennies
l'investissement des entreprises a cru
encore de 2,3% ce trimestre tandis que
la consommation des ménages c'est
maintenu la situation de l'emploi
constitue un autre indicateur positif
puisque les créations d'emplois sont
restées dynamiques au troisième
trimestre encore au mois de septembre
nous avons comptabilisé 60 000 chômeurs
de moins s'agissant de ce qui nous
attend pour ce quatrième trimestre les
signaux et indicateurs dont nous
disposons sont plutôt favorables qu'il
s'agisse de l'activité des intentions
d'embauche ou de l'investissement des
entreprises
bien entendu le niveau élevé d'inflation
suscite des inquiétudes du côté des
ménages comme des chefs d'entreprises la
hausse des prix en effet rebondit à 6,2%
en octobre après 5,6% en septembre pour
autant ce niveau reste cohérent avec la
prévision adossée à ce deuxième PLFR
c'est à dire une inflation de 5,3 % en
moyenne annuelle jugé elle aussi
crédible par le Haut Conseil des
finances publiques
nous ne voulons pas la phase nous avons
l'inflation la moins élevée de toute la
zone euro mais la dynamique de hausse
des prix fait encore des dégâts le texte
que nous vous présentons aujourd'hui
permet d'assurer le financement de
mesure qui vont changer le quotidien des
français tout en procédant à un certain
nombre d'ajustements dans une logique
très classique de fin de gestion comme
le PLF de juillet ce texte traduit
d'abord une volonté de soutenir et de
protéger pour ma part il me semble
qu'une large majorité peut se retrouver
derrière cet objectif et j'ai pu
constater à l'Assemblée nationale que ce
texte a été adopté classiquement si
j'ose le terme 149-3 du fait du vote
évidemment de la majorité présidentielle
mais aussi de l'abstention constructive
des groupes les républicains les groupes
socialistes et du groupe l'IoT
ce qui vous est proposé aujourd'hui
c'est une rallonge de 2,5 milliards
d'euros oui une rallonge qui va
notamment permettre d'aider 12 millions
de ménages à payer leurs factures
énergétique qui se chauffent au gaz à
l'électricité au bois ou fioul avec ce
texte nous mettons donc un milliard 800
millions d'euros sur la table pour
financer ce chèque énergie exceptionnel
concrètement c'est un versement de 100 à
200 euros qui sera effectué d'ici la fin
de l'année j'en profite pour rappeler
que la première loi de finance
rectificative a prévu un budget de 230
millions d'euros pour aider les Ménas
qui se chauffent au fioul cette aide
commence à être versée et se traduit par
l'attribution d'un chèque énergie de 200
euros pour les ménages déjà
bénéficiaires du chèque énergie et de
100 euros pour les ménages des 3e à 5e
des cils il y avait un angle mort les
ménages qui se chauffent au bois il
fallait corriger cela car ils sont quand
même 3,4 millions dans notre pays
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
travaillé avec l'ensemble des groupes
politiques à l'Assemblée nationale pour
mettre en place une aide exceptionnelle
pour les ménages qui utilisent le bois
comme mode de chauffage au-delà des 230
millions d'euros que nous avons débloqué
pour alléger la facture d'une partie de
nos compatriotes je le dis avec clarté
et fermeté nous voulons aussi lutter
contre l'opacité du marché du bois de
chauffage et les comportements
spéculatifs qui nuisent à des ménages
qui sont déjà parfois en grande
difficulté ce texte finance un autre
choix que nous avons fait depuis le 1er
avril celui soutenir les automobilistes
vous le savez la première ministre avait
annoncé jusqu'à la mi-novembre la
prolongation de l'Aristote de 30
centimes par litre pour tenir compte du
blocage des raffineries et des
difficultés d'approvisionnement dont on
patient nos compatriotes
cette prolongation a représenté un coup
pour nos finances publiques de 440
millions d'euros pour deux semaines de
prolongation et ce PLF permet d'en
assurer la régularisation et le
financement depuis ce matin et jusqu'au
31 décembre cette remise à la pompe est
réduite à 10 centimes par litre comme
nous l'avions annoncé pour autant 2023
ne sera pas synonyme d'un arrêt brutal
du soutien apporté aux automobilistes
nous avons toujours dit que cette
histoire à la pompe avait vocation à
être ciblée dans le temps et temporaire
parce qu'elle coûte très cher au
finances publiques l'aristo on a la
pompe aura coûté sur l'année 2022 8
milliards d'euros 8 milliards d'euros
l'équivalent du budget du ministère de
la Justice 30 millions d'euros par jour
pour la ristourne pour un dispositif qui
n'est pas ciblé sur les Français qui en
ont le plus besoin et on pense
évidemment à ceux qui ont besoin leur
véhicule pour aller travailler souvent
avec des revenus modestes un système qui
finance aussi le plein de résidents de
pays voisins de la France qui viennent
faire leur plein dans notre pays au
frais du contribuable français nous
assumons d'avoir pris cette mesure nous
assumons d'avoir pris cette mesure dans
le courant de l'année 2022 elle était
nécessaire dans l'urgence pour soutenir
les Français en moyenne un automobiliste
français aura économisé 120 euros
d'essence grâce à cette mesure
j'ajouterai 40 euros pour ceux qui
fréquentent les stations totales qui ont
elle-même appliquer une ristourne mais
la réalité c'est que si nous devons
continuer à soutenir les Français nous
devons concentrer notre soutien vers
ceux qui travaillent et qui ont besoin
de leur voiture le président de la
République l'a dit un dispositif ciblé
sur ces travailleurs sera mis en place
il s'agit en effet d'agir de manière
plus ciblée en concentrant l'argent
public sur celles et ceux qui en ont le
plus besoin vous le voyez ce PLFR est
donc un texte dont les mesures
contribueront à améliorer le quotidien
de nos compatriotes dans ces moments
difficiles
aussi un texte de soutien aux opérateurs
de l'État face à l'envoler des prix de
l'énergie je pense notamment aux
universités aux établissements de
recherche et aux CROUS afin de les aider
à payer leurs factures nous avons ainsi
prévu une enveloppe de 275 millions
d'euros immédiatement débloqués au
bénéfice des opérateurs du ministère de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche nous savons avec ma collègue
Sylvie retaillot que certaines
universités étaient tentés de
privilégier l'enseignement à distance
pour leurs étudiants pour limiter leurs
factures d'électricité de chauffage et
d'éclairage pour notre part nous
préférons des amphis remplis et éclairés
même si cela doit mobiliser de manière
ponctuelle de l'argent public dans la
même logique ce PLFR prévoit l'ouverture
de crédit pour les frais de carburant
exceptionnels du ministère des armées
200 millions d'euros pour assurer
l'augmentation des coûts des carburants
opérationnels pour nos soldats engagés
en opération extérieure et vont
permettre de rendre hommage à leur
engagement et à leur dévouement
aujourd'hui partout dans le monde
ce sont ainsi deux milliards 500
millions d'euros qui sont mis sur la
table pour aider les Français et
certains opérateurs de l'État à faire
face aux chocs énergétiques mais dans ce
texte il ne s'agit pas simplement de
parler à l'urgence il s'agit aussi de
procéder un certain nombre d'ajustements
de fin de gestion avec le souci
permanent de tenir les comptes publics
au global les ouvertures de crédit
auxquelles nous procédons pour assurer
de nouvelles dépenses elles sont de
l'ordre de 5 milliards d'euros sont
compensés par des annulations de crédit
d'un montant
identique autrement dit nous vous
présentons aujourd'hui un texte
d'équilibre budgétaire hors dépenses
exceptionnelles liées à la crise de
l'énergie il y a les 2 milliards 500
millions d'euros ponctuels exceptionnels
liés à la crise de l'énergie que je
viens de vous détailler il y a par
ailleurs 5 milliards d'euros d'ouverture
de crédit que je vais détailler
rapidement dans un instant mais ces 5
milliards d'euros d'ouverture de crédit
sont intégralement compensés par des
annulations de crédit pour un montant
équivalent la principale ouverture de
crédit à hauteur de 2 milliards d'euros
permet de poursuivre le développement de
la formation profession personnel et de
l'apprentissage ce sont ainsi deux
milliards d'euros de crédit que nous
ouvrons pour financer France compétences
afin d'aider chaque Français à
construire son avenir professionnel
c'est 2 milliards d'euros sont aussi la
traduction du formidable défi que nous
sommes en train de relever sur
l'apprentissage après des années où nous
avions fini par croire que cela était
impossible pour autant je n'ignore pas
les critiques qui ont été formulées ici
rappeler notamment lors de mon audition
en commission des finances nous avions
déjà eu ce débat cet été au moment du
précédent PLFR au sein duquel nous
avions déjà ouvert des crédits pour
France compétences et évidemment qu'il
faut que nous continuions à nous
attacher à permettre à France
compétences de réaliser des économistes
structurelles pour revenir vers un
équilibre budgétaire et vous savez que
dans le cadre du projet de loi de
finances des mesures très fortes
d'économie budgétaire pour France
compétences sont prévus
autre ouverture significative 1 milliard
100 millions d'euros sont ouverts pour
la mission défense afin de financer le
soutien militaire que nous apportons à
l'Ukraine dernière ouverture que je
souhaite mentionner dans ce propos
liminaire celle de 450 millions d'euros
pour prolonger le financement des
mesures d'indemnisation des crises
agricoles survenues cette année
évidemment bénéfice de nos agriculteurs
qui ont été particulièrement sinistrés
par des épisodes de sécheresse des
épisodes de grêle
encore ces derniers mois en contrepartie
nous procédons à des annulations de
crédit d'un montant équivalent qui ont
pour effet de couvrir intégralement les
ouvertures que je viens de présenter
j'imagine que nous aurons l'occasion d'y
revenir durant ce débat je vous disais
que notre premier objectif est d'aider
l'économie française à absorber le choc
l'autre objectif qui est évidemment
aussi particulièrement essentiel et
important il en va aussi de notre
souveraineté de notre indépendance et
aussi la protection des français dans
les années à venir c'est évidemment
celui de tenir nos comptes conformément
aux engagements que nous avons pris
vis-à-vis de nos partenaires européens
et vis-à-vis des Français je le disais
alors dépense exceptionnelles liées à la
crise de l'énergie nous vous présentons
aujourd'hui un texte sans ouverture
nette de crédit notre pays malgré les
aléas je le dis ne cède pas un pouce de
terrain au laisser aller budgétaire nous
sommes conformes à la trajectoire qui a
été annoncée par le président de la
République dans le cadre de la campagne
présidentielle d'une réduction
progressive de notre déficit public pour
revenir sous les 3% d'ici à 2027 le
déficit public était de 8,9% en 2020 il
est passé à 6,5% en 2021 il sera très
légèrement en dessous de 5% cette année
et nous avons pour ambition de le
ramener tous les trois pourcents d'ici à
cette trajectoire de sérieux qui je le
redis n'a rien à voir avec l'austérité
nous la tiendrons en 2023 et pour les
années suivantes afin d'assurer la
stabilisation de notre dette puis le
retour du déficit sous la barre des 3%.
je sais que la majorité sénatoriale
souhaite que nous allions plus loin ou
plutôt que nous allions en plus vite
dans la consolidation des finances
publiques nous avons eu ce débat à
plusieurs reprises dans des textes
récents et nous aurons encore l'occasion
ensemble dans d'échanger dans les
prochains jours et les prochaines
semaines nous devons par ailleurs au
moment où la croissance ralentit
notamment en Europe prêtez attention à
une baisse trop brutale qui pourrait
avoir des effets pro cycliques si on l'a
dessus les leçons des politiques qui ont
été conduites après la crise de 2008
2010 il ne s'agit pas ici de remettre en
question la gestion de l'époque je crois
que chaque gouvernement apprend aussi
des enseignements de la gestion des
crises qui on peut survenir par le passé
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs vous le
voyez cette rallonge anti-inflation ou
la financement tout en poursuivant notre
objectif de maîtrise des comptes publics
2022 n'est pas seulement l'année du
combat contre la vie chère c'est aussi
l'année du combat pour des comptes
bientôt cette maîtrise des comptes est
possible grâce à une économie qui
résiste grâce à l'engagement et au
travail de chacun avec ce projet de loi
de finance rectificative nous aidons les
Français à se chauffer à se déplacer
nous aidons nos étudiants et nos
chercheurs à travailler dans de bonnes
conditions nous poursuivons le
financement de la bataille en faveur du
plein emploi et nous assumons notre
choix de nous tenir aux côtés du peuple
ukrainien ces objectifs je pense qu'une
immense majorité des Français les
soutiens et parce que les Français n'ont
tout simplement pas les moyens
d'attendre il nous revient d'agir au
service de l'intérêt de notre pays je
vous remercie
merci la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur rapporteur général de la
commission des finances Jean-François
Husson
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission mes chers collègues
nous examinons aujourd'hui le second
projet black finance rectificatif pour
que l'on qualifie habituellement de tel
fr de fin de gestion le principal
objectif de ce texte et vous le savez et
de procéder à diverses ajustements
ouverture et annulation de crédit sur le
budget de l'État j'y reviendrai mais en
réalité l'examen à l'Assemblée nationale
a conduit à aller plus loin monsieur le
ministre en introduisant aussi des
mesures fiscales pérennes cette année
revenant d'ailleurs sur une pratique
établie depuis 2018
s'agissant du scénario Macron économique
retenu par le gouvernement celui-ci
anticipe une croissance du PIB de 2,7%
en 2022 ce qui est conforme au dépôt au
dépôt pardon du projet loi de finance
pour 2023 nous sommes malgré tout bien
loin de la croissance économique que
nous attendions lors de l'examen du PLF
pour 2022 puisqu'elle était à l'époque à
environ 4% depuis c'est vrai de nombreux
chocs sont venus ralentir la progression
de l'activité économique dont le plus
important reste bien évidemment la
hausse des prix de l'énergie la
prévision retenue par le gouvernement se
situe en fait dans la borne haute de la
prévision du consensus des économistes
mais elle ne paraît pas pour autant
inatteignable le ralentissement de
l'activité au troisième trimestre plaide
plutôt en fait pour une croissance
autour de 2,5%
en ce qui concerne l'état des finances
publiques le gouvernement prévoit un
déficit de 4,9% du PIB je crois même
savoir que sera finalement 5 qui serait
donc conforme à celui
présenté lors du PLF pour 2023 une
nouvelle fois illustration de nos
échanges lors de l'examen de la du
projet de loi de programmation
l'ensemble du déficit se réporté par
l'État puisque les administrations
locales et les administrations sociales
seraient en excédent ou à l'équilibre
cette légère amélioration laisse tout de
même nos comptes publics dans un état
plus que préoccupant elle s'explique à
la fois par des anticipations de
recettes plus importantes en matière de
prélèvement sociaux et d'impôt sur leurs
revenus et des dépenses moindres liées à
des économies de constatation avec tout
de même un peu plus de 172 milliards
d'euros le déficit budgétaire de l'État
serait finalement supérieure de 18,5
milliards d'euros par rapport à la
prévision en loi de finance initiale
mais inférieurs c'est vrai de 6
milliards par rapport à la première loi
de finance rectificative de l'été
dernier lors de l'examen du texte par
l'Assemblée le solde a été dégradé de
près d'un demi
milliards d'euros principalement par une
augmentation des dépenses du budget
général alors dans les grandes masses
l'amélioration de la prévision du
déficit par rapport à la loi de finance
rectificative s'explique d'abord par une
révision en hausse des recettes net et
du moindre niveau attendu pour le
prélèvement sur recette à destination de
l'Union européenne mais l'amélioration
du sol provient également d'une
consommation moindre de crédit reporté
puisque seul
7,6 milliards d'euros devrait être
consommé sur plus excusez du peu de 23
milliards d'euros reportés la pratique
des reports monsieur le ministre est de
plus en plus courante à titre d'exemple
seulement 245 millions d'euros sont
annulés sur le programme 134
développement des entreprises et
régulations de la mission économique
mais ce programme dispose toujours de
4,5 milliards d'euros non consommés car
de très importants crédits ont été
découvert en ouvert en cours d'année
pour financer des dispositifs d'aide aux
entreprises face à l'inflation mais ont
été très très peu utilisés ces crédits
vont probablement être à nouveau et
massivement reporté sur 203
j'ai déjà indiqué à plusieurs reprises
comme la Cour des comptes d'ailleurs
monsieur le ministre cette pratique
n'est pas satisfaisante elle est report
massifs à cet auteur ne devrait plus
être pratiquée la commission des
finances d'ailleurs va vous montrer
l'exemple puisqu'elle vous propose un
amendement tendant à supprimer d'ores et
déjà 4 milliards d'euros qui n'auront
aucune utilité cette année au titre des
participations financières de l'État
quoi qu'il en soit le déficit demeure
considérable puisqu'il est à peu près
identique à celui atteint en 2020 et en
2021 et qu'il est deux fois plus élevé
que le déficit constaté au cours des
années 2011 à 2019
le projet de loi de finance
certificative apparaît pardon sous peu
toutefois un niveau exceptionnel de
dépenses en fin d'année avec une
dégradation de près de 25 milliards
d'euros dans les trois derniers mois de
l'année il est vrai que des dépenses
importantes sont prévues au titre
notamment des mesures de protection
contre l'inflation mais il est bien
possible une nouvelle fois que des
crédits importants demeurent non
utilisées à la fin de l'année je l'ai
déjà dit je vous le redis en toute état
de cause et je reviendrai demain pour le
projet de loi de finance 2023 qui
continue malheureusement sur cette
trajectoire on est en quelque sorte sur
un plateau de déficit pour ne pas dire
un abîme si on considère le solde dont
il me paraît bien difficile de sortir
le niveau des recettes ne varie pas de
manière fondamentale malgré de bonnes
nouvelles qui se poursuivent sur l'impôt
sur les sociétés et l'impôt sur le
revenu mais je l'indique à l'instant ce
collectif budgétaire a aussi cinq
articles comprenant des dispositions
fiscales dont la portée va au-delà de
l'année 2022 l'article 9e jusqu'à
modifier un article du code général des
impôts qui est également modifié par
l'article 7 du PLF concernant la taxe
d'aménagement
cependant je ne proposerai pas de
remettre en cause la plupart de ces
dispositions dont l'ajout dans le texte
résulte aussi il faut le souligner du
caractère particulier de l'examen du PLF
par l'Assemblée nationale la commission
des finances propose toutefois de
supprimer l'article 9c relatif à la
répartition entre les collectivités
territoriales et leurs groupements du
produit de la composante de l'ifère
relative au centrale photovoltaïque en
effet je m'en explique le sujet de la
répartition de cette recette ne peut
être traité à la va-vite dans un
collectif de fin d'année c'est un sujet
de loi de finance initiale et nous
allons d'ailleurs en débuter son examen
demain ça tombe bien
pour les années à venir comme nous
l'avons prévu en révisant la loi
organique relative aux lois de finances
il conviendra de revenir à une
séparation nette entre le collectif
budgétaire qui ajuste les crédits en fin
d'année et le PLF qui prépare le budget
disposition fiscale mais c'est bien du
côté des dépenses que le PLF r apporte
le plus de modifications avec des
ouvertures qui dépassent de loin les
annulations des ouvertures de crédit
concerne de nombreux programmes du
budget général une subvention à France
compétence qui vient finalement combler
une fois de plus le puits sans fond de
cette trésorerie à hauteur de 2
milliards pour autant l'équilibre
financiers pérennes de l'opérateur n'est
toujours pas assuré il nous faut donc
trouver une trajectoire soutenable à
l'avenir pour le financement de la
formation professionnelle le niveau
élevé de l'inflation plus facilement des
prix de l'énergie restent une des
principales causes ouvertures de crédit
il s'agit là par exemple du chèque
énergie mais aussi exceptionnel mais de
la prolongation de l'armée car que vous
avez évoqué à l'instant monsieur le
ministre je me félicite de l'apport de
40 millions d'euros supplémentaires aux
associations d'aide alimentaire comme
nous l'avions fait au PLF de l'été en ce
qui concerne le Sénat un nouveau
programme d'un milliard 4 qui doit aussi
compenser à la sécurité sociale le coût
de dons des vaccins à des pays tiers et
reversés une partie des sommes reçus de
l'Union européenne dans le cadre du plan
de relance et au titre du volet Ségur
investissement et c'est pour compenser à
la sécurité sociale le coût des
allègements des cotisations sociales
dans le cadre de la crise sanitaire
qu'un milliard 3 sont également ouverts
sur la mission plan d'urgence que la loi
de finances initiale n'avait pas prévu
autre dépense à noter vous l'avez dit
qui concerne la défense pour l'Ukraine
parallèlement à ces nouvelles dépenses
les annulations correspondent à des
économies de consolidation à hauteur de
2 milliards d'euros annulés par exemple
sur les appels en garantie de l'État au
titre des PGE 1 milliard également
annulé pour les dépenses de la mission
plan d'urgence face à la crise sanitaire
qui était des crédits d'ailleurs
reportés de 2021
s'agissant et pour finir des effectifs
la régularisation opérée par le texte
conduit à une hausse de 1081 emplois je
ne vous cache pas que notre commission
des finances en est étonné et notamment
s'agissant des 53 emplois créés au sein
des services de Premier ministre y
compris d'ailleurs pour le Conseil
national de la refondation même si le
nombre en est symbolique au final notre
commission des finances propose
d'adopter les mesures proposées par le
gouvernement ou adopter à la sonnation
nationale à l'Assemblée nationale qui
s'inscrivent dans une direction que nous
soutenons que ce soit le chèque énergie
exceptionnel que soit le doublement du
seuil d'imputation du déficit foncier
sur le revenu global pour les dépenses
de rénovation énergétique ou du soutien
à l'achat des pellets et bûches de bois
ainsi que le nouveau dispositif plus
favorable de ma prime rénov nous
proposons également l'ouverture de deux
enveloppes destinées à renforcer les
moyens alloués d'une part pour la
réflexion des ponts notamment des
petites communes avec 60 millions
d'euros supplémentaires et d'autre part
pour veiller à la réduction du taux de
fuite du réseau d'eau et accélérer sa
rénovation un enjeu crucial et urgent
compte tenu de la sécheresse de cette
année l'amendement proposera donc un
abondement de 100 millions d'euros sous
les bénéfices des différents
observations et sans oublier pardon
France service puisque nous allons
également abonder le budget la
commission des finances vous propose
d'adopter ce projet de loi de finance
rectificative tel qu'il sera modifié par
les amendements que nous voterons je
vous remercie
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à Monsieur Christian
Billac pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique social européen
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
nous examinons le deuxième projet de loi
de finance rectificative pour 2022 et je
dois vous dire bravo monsieur le
ministre
je ne sais pas si vous avez emprunté
l'hélicoptère bleu ou l'hélicoptère
rouge comme dans l'émission télévisées
mais vous avez remporté la chasse au
trésor
car lorsqu'on examine ce deuxième projet
de loi de finance explicative on
constate que ce n'est pas un trésor que
vous avez trouvé mes deux
5,2 milliards d'euros de choses
supplémentaire fiscale en fiscale mais
aussi
3,8 milliards de crédit non consommés
mais comme je l'ai Souvigné en
commission des finances à tout prendre
je préfère qu'il y a des trésors cachés
que de déficits cachés
vous avez donc gagné cette chasse au
trésor et nous arrivons à équilibrer ce
second pellet faire sans faire appel à
l'emprunt ce qui est rare et en offrant
un soutien aux entreprises aux
particuliers actuellement frappé de
plein fouet par la crise énergétique
c'est une bonne chose de faire face à
l'urgence même si je ne suis pas un
farouche partisan de la politique du
chèque
ainsi ce projet de loi de finance
rectificative me convient beaucoup mieux
que le projet de loi de programmation
des finances publiques dont j'avais dit
qu'il manquait de souffle et d'ambition
mais le contexte géopolitique nous
invite à rester prudent sur les
prévisions de croissance économique
soit 2,7% du PIB pour 2022
légèrement plus optimiste que dans la
première loi des finances rectificative
mais inférieur aux 4% qu'on prévoyant
2021 le Conseil des finances publiques
estime que ces prévisions de croissance
d'inflation du gouvernement reste
crédible un peu élevé mais sans être
hors d'atteinte le niveau d'inflation et
le déficit quelque peu sous-estimer mais
comme vous l'avez souligné monsieur le
ministre la prévision macroéconomique et
décidément un exercice forte aléatoire
par les temps qui courent
de fin d'exercice major la fraction de
TVA affecter la sécurité sociale
premier pour garantir la neutralité
financière et compenser la baisse des
cotisations
portant mesures d'urgence pour la
protection du pouvoir d'achat l'article
3 traduit l'incidence sur l'équilibre
budgétaire en 2022 des dispositions du
président PLFR et la révélation des
recettes le sol de budgétaire s'améliore
légèrement grâce à la hausse des
recettes fiscales donc j'en ai parlé de
2 milliards 8 pour l'impôt sur le revenu
2 milliards 3 pour l'impôt sur la
société 1 milliard virgule deux pour la
TVA et une baisse de 2,3 milliards de
prélève recette mais quand même le
déficit public continue de rester à du
sale avec un peu plus de 162 milliards
d'euros
l'article 4 représente 6,3 milliards de
nouvelles autorisations d'engagement et
de crise de paiement pour le budget
général les principales conscients
agriculture avec 449 millions la dépense
un peu plus d'un milliard l'écologie en
milliard et demi les remboursements et
dégrèvement de meilleur artiste la santé
meilleur 3 le travail et l'emploi de
milliards
budgétaires ont été votés par
l'Assemblée nationale
100 millions d'euros pour la défense 260
millions pour l'écologie de l'aide pour
le bois de chauffage m'imprime rénove
pour la cosse pour les associations
d'alimentaires avec 42 millions ou
encore pour lui faire
l'article 6 prévoit 439 millions en
euros
d'autorisation de l'engagement et 442
millions d'euros en crédits de paiement
principalement pour les amas
collectivités locales
quant à l'article 5 il prévoit
l'équivalent de 907 équivalent en plein
d'autorisation d'emploi de l'État bon il
faut renforcer les dispositifs de lutte
contre les violences entre familiales et
la justice de proximité
enfin l'article 9 concerne le chèque
énergie ayant bénéficié à plus de 5
millions de ménages et se décline en
nouvelle modalité d'application vous
l'avez dit qui viseront plus
particulièrement ce qui travaille comme
je l'ai souligné malgré le déficit
important je me prononcerai pour ma part
en faveur de ce PLF même je le répète si
la politique du chèque n'est pas ma
tasse de thé les mêmes infantilisantes
mais il faut le faire dans l'urgence
quatre groupes rdfe comme à la coutumée
il s'exprimera en fonction de la teneur
de débat mais sera largement majoritaire
à ce texte je vous remercie merci
la parole et maintenant Monsieur Arnaud
Bazin pour le groupe les républicains
madame le présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
c'est un exercice classique qu'un PLF de
fin de gestion et celui-ci ne dérogerait
pas au peu d'intérêt que peuvent
susciter habituellement quelques
ajustements une idéerogerait pas
quelques détails près tout d'abord une
dépense nouvelle de près de 2 milliards
et demi pour faire face à la hausse de
l'énergie un chèque énergie exceptionnel
bien peu exceptionnelle dans cette année
d'élection présidentielle aura été
l'année d'échecs 12 millions de foyers
sur le critère du revenu fiscal serait
concerné un dispositif bricolé dans
l'urgence qui ne fait aucune différence
à revenus égal entre le locataire d'un
logement social bien isolé et chauffé à
l'électricité 15% d'augmentation sur une
base faible et celui du propriétaire
d'une passoire thermique chauffée au
fioul au moins 50% d'augmentation sur
une base élevée
certes l'exercice d'équité est difficile
mais on touche bien là aux limites de
l'exercice du chèque on peut en dire
autant de la prolongation de la remise
carburant 440 millions d'euros pour deux
semaines
inquiétant également et la rallonge de 2
milliards d'euros consentis à France
compétences elle survient en effet après
une première rallonge du même montant au
premier PLF et précède un effort
d'encore de milliards annoncé au PLF
2023 qui s'ajoute aux 3 milliards et
demi de supplément pour l'augmentation
des contrats d'apprentissage si on peut
apprécier l'effort pour l'alternance on
peut en revanche salarmée de ces 6
milliards d'euros correspondant à des
besoins urgents de trésorerie de France
compétences
sachant qu'un tiers des dépenses de
cette organisme est relatif à la
formation et considérant le catalogue
parfois surprenant de ces formations je
crois qu'il y aura là matière à contrôle
parlementaire
les autres dépenses sont plus légitimes
l'activité opérationnelle des forces
armées les aides aux agriculteurs les
équipements militaires pour l'Ukraine
pour un total global de 7 milliards et
demi de dépenses nouvelles tout de même
on regarde il y aurait 5 milliards
d'euros d'annulation de crédit soit 2
milliards au titre du psg-e et 500
millions au titre de dépenses
accidentelles dont nous avions dit
qu'elles étaient surestimer
voilà pour le texte
mais c'est le contexte qui me paraît le
plus intéressant
nous devrions terminer l'année 2022 avec
un solde certes en amélioration par
rapport à l'estimation initiale mais un
solde négatif quand même de près de 165
milliards d'euros soit plus de la moitié
des recettes de fonctionnement et sur
les 4,9% du produit intérieur brut que
cela représente près des trois quarts
relèvent du structurel
pour la même année 2022 l'Allemagne
comptera un déficit de 2,6 points de PIB
presque deux fois moins que nous et la
moyenne des pays de l'Union européenne
sera à -3,8 nous aurons donc cette année
encore l'un des pires déficits en Europe
et pourtant nous avons le niveau de
prélèvement obligatoire le plus élevé
des 38 pays de l'OCDE avec la Finlande
et le Danemark il est vrai
52,8%. ce qui relativise les discours
triomphalistes du Gouvernement en la
matière
comment peut-on parvenir à un tel
déficit quand on a un tel taux de
prélèvement obligatoire en laissant
filer la dépense publique bien sûr
c'est les dépenses publiques augmentent
même diminuer des dépenses
exceptionnelles le taux de dépenses
publiques en France en 2022 demeurent
plus important qu'en 2012 qu'en 2017 et
qu'en 2019 il est surtout le plus élevé
de l'Union européenne
a contrario des administrations de
l'État les collectivités territoriales
ont pour leur part et comme toujours
jouer le jeu de la maîtrise et de la
dépense publique puisqu'en 2022 le
déficit des administrations publiques
locales est égale à 0
le rapporteur général la rappeler tout à
l'heure et cela son système de
contrainte ce qui n'a pas empêché le
gouvernement de prévoir contrainte et
sanctions à l'article 23 du prêt du
récent projet de loi de programmation
des finances publiques heureusement
supprimé par notre assemblée et qui
reviendra et là au progrès de au projet
de loi de finances 2023 sous forme d'un
article 40 quater
c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
le Sénat a exigé que l'État fasse autant
d'efforts que ce qu'il demande aux
collectivités en alignant les deux
trajectoires budgétaires dans cette loi
de programmation des finances publiques
dont je parlais
le fonctionnement courant de notre état
est donc financé par la dette de la
France l'une des plus élevées de l'Union
Européenne en 2012 à la fin du
quinquennat Sarkozy notre pays avait un
endettement de
90,6 % du PIB exactement dans la moyenne
de la zone euro qui était à 90,7
en 2022 à la fin de cette année après
les quinquennats Hollande et Macron la
France a un endettement de
111,5% du produit intérieur brut contre
95% dans la zone euro et l'Allemagne
quant à elle est à 66%
si en face de ces records très négatifs
bien évidemment en termes de dette de
dépenses publiques de prélèvements
obligatoires nous constations un faible
taux de chômage une vraie
industrialisation avec une balance du
commerce extérieur favorable grâce à
l'investissement des services publics de
bons niveaux qui concourent au bien-être
quotidien des Français peut être
verrions-nous ces chiffres d'un autre
œil mais là aussi le diagnostic est
sombre certes sur le ministre vous
l'avez rappelé le chômage a baissé
depuis 2017 mais reste supérieure à la
moyenne européenne
7,1% septembre 2022 contre 6,6 dans
l'Union européenne et 3% en Allemagne
et encore cette baisse est-elle en
partie due à la mise en formation de
nombreux demandeurs d'emploi
alors même qu'il semble que six acteurs
économiques sur dix éprouvent des
difficultés sévères voire dramatique de
recrutement que des centaines de
milliers de poste sont vacants dans de
très nombreux secteurs y compris dans
l'emploi public nous comptons quasiment
3 millions de chômeurs de catégories
enfin le déficit commercial bat tous les
records et dépassera probablement 200
milliards d'euros 31 décembre 2022 nous
sommes déjà à plus de 143 milliards à
septembre
en 2021 déjà un nouveau record
s'établissait à -110 milliards quand
l'Allemagne ont Grangé un excédent de
179 milliards
quant au service public leur état est
peut-être encore plus préoccupant que
les chiffres calamiteux des indicateurs
des finances publiques si on hésite sur
le sort de l'hôpital c'est qu'on ne sait
pas trop dire s'il va craquer un
séchagement ou s'il a déjà craqué la
médecine de ville n'est guère en
meilleur état les territoires où la
couverture des besoins en généraliste ne
parlons même pas des spécialistes et
corrects sont de rares îlots dans une
France de désert médicaux les ministères
et leurs administrations sont tellement
efficaces qu'il a fallu en 2021 recourir
à des cabinets de conseils pour éclairer
les choix stratégiques pour un montant
supérieur à 1 milliard d'euros et pour
l'éducation moins d'élèves plus de
dépenses égales une constante
dégradation du niveau des élèves dans
les classements internationaux
quant au service public décentralisé ils
ont été réduits comme peau de chagrin
l'usager voudra bien s'en remettre au
numérique s'il le peut et quand il
fonctionne ou alors trouver une maison
France service en partie aujourd'hui au
frais des collectivités locales et en
totalité de main il n'y a guère de doute
pourtant ce PLFR dans son article 7
augmente le plafond d'emploi plus de 900
et TPT pour l'État plus de 170 pour ces
opérateurs plus de fonctionnaires une
masse salariale qui augmente en 2022 est
toujours moins de services dans nos
territoires et le PLF 2023 que nous
examinerons dès demain va poursuivre et
amplifier
amplifier la dette publique 2800
milliards d'euros soit 42000 euros par
français augmenter l'emprunt nous serons
à 270 milliards dont 57 milliards pour
le service de la dette
ce bilan aurait dû sonner comme une
alarme pour le gouvernement mais il n'en
est rien
mes chers collègues quand nous nous
regardons nous nous désolons et quand
nous nous comparons à nos voisins la
désolation est encore plus complète au
travers des quelques chiffres que je
vous ai exposé monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues en outre l'hiver arrive
je vous remercie de votre attention
merci la parole est à Franck Menonville
pour le groupe Les Indépendants
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
nous examinons cet après-midi et nous
l'espérons le dernier projet de loi de
finance rectification pour 2020
certes ce texte 2022 certes ce texte
remplit sa mission de collectif
budgétaire de fin de gestion mais il
contient également plusieurs mesures
nouvelles
les principales sont dictées par
l'urgence de la situation que nous nous
vivons et notamment en lien avec
l'inflation
il vise à atténuer les coûts liés à la
hausse des prix de l'énergie et c'est
notamment le cas du chèque énergie
exceptionnelle d'un montant de 100 ou
200 euros qui sera versé au ménage les
plus modestes ce dispositif et le
bienvenu car il permet de mieux cibler
les efforts budgétaires sur ceux qui ont
le plus besoin et de compléter ainsi les
dispositifs déjà mis en place
antérieurement
c'est une réalité que nous constatons
l'inflation ne fera pas tous les
Français avec la même intensité elle
pénalise les ruraux plus que les urbains
et les publics précaires plus que les
classes favorisées proportionnellement
en effet pour les plus précaires la part
de l'énergie dans le revenu disponible
et le plus élevé et que dans le reste de
la population et nous vous devons donc
concentrer nos efforts sur les ménages
les moins favorisés il est également
nécessaire que ce dispositif concerne
bien toutes les sources d'énergie pour
ça c'est pourquoi donc que la création
d'une aide de 230 millions d'euros pour
les ménages se sont faits en bois
pellets et bûche
calqué sur le chèque exceptionnel fioul
est une avancée à souligner que je
soutiens pleinement
en complément j'ai proposé un amendement
pour étendre le bénéfice du taux de TVA
réduit au pellet et au granulés de bois
et plaquettes le prolongement de la
ristourne sur le prix du carburant à la
pompe permet aussi de répondre au
préoccupations des Français qui
subissent deux points forts les coûts du
carburant on est fait si ce dispositif
n'est pas ciblé puisqu'il n'est pas
soumis à des conditions de ressources il
vise avant tout nos compatriotes qui ont
qui ont d'autres choix que de prendre
leur voiture cette mesure évite la
complexité d'un accès sous conditions et
s'adresse prioritairement à la ruralité
c'est un facteur de cohésion sociale en
ces temps de fortes inflation mais par
ailleurs nous avons déjà pu constater
plusieurs formes de détournement de
cette mesure
c'est particulièrement le cas dans le
grand test où nous voyons de nombreux
transfrontaliers belges luxembourgeois
allemand ou Suisse venir en France pour
bénéficier donc des prix réduits grâce
aux impôts des Français nous devons donc
y remédier et mieux cibler ses aides de
ce point de vue nous saluons donc le
dispositif gros rouleur dans les
contours
ne sont pas encore précisés ils semblent
mieux répondre néanmoins aux impératifs
de justice sociale et d'efficacité
budgétaire il est impératif que nos
dispositifs cibles davantage les
travailleurs dans notre département de
la Meuse cher Gérard
par exemple
82 % d'entre eux prennent leur voiture
pour aller travailler c'est à eux qu'il
faut s'adresser nous devons rassurer les
Français sur la vente sur notre volonté
pour assurer une meilleure valorisation
du travail force et de constater que la
flambée du prix de l'énergie fragilise
nos concitoyens qui doivent prendre
chaque jour leur voiture pour se rendre
à leur travail et en particulier dans
les territoires ruraux ce pellet faire a
donc aussi été enrichi de plusieurs
propositions de l'Assemblée nationale
dans nombre d'entre elles nous semblent
pertinentes comme l'ajustement apporté à
ma priorellove ou encore l'extension de
l'exonération permanente de la taxe
foncière pour les bâtiments ruraux
affecter un usage agricole je pense
également la réforme de l'ifère sur le
photovoltaïque au bénéfice des communes
cette mesure reprend une proposition que
nous portions dans notre groupe depuis
plusieurs années certes elle n'a sans
doute pas sa place dans le PLFR mais
j'espère qu'elle pourra rapidement être
mise en place elle renforcera en effet
l'acceptabilité locale des énergies
renouvelables par latératoralisation des
recettes fiscales notre groupe salut
l'augmentation des effectifs également
du mystère de la justice en espérant que
cela améliore l'efficacité et la
célérité de la réponse judiciaire sur
l'ensemble du territoire national c'est
une forte et légitime attend de nos
concitoyens notamment d'autres
augmentations interrogent toutes ne
répondent pas à l'urgence de la
situation et devrait plutôt figurer et
être intégré dans le PLF au ces réserves
et pour l'essentiel des dispositions
nous considérons que ce texte va dans le
bon sens et permettra de renforcer le
pouvoir d'achat des Français
merci la parole est maintenant Monsieur
Daniel broyer pour le groupe écologie
solidarité territoire
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur général
monsieur le Président chers collègues
au risque de surprendre permettez-moi de
démarrer ce propos par des félicitations
sur le ministre
ce projet de loi de finances
rectificative de fin d'année contient
des mesures pour soutenir les ministères
les plus touchés par l'envolée des prix
et c'était important que ce soit le cas
je souligne plus précisément les 275
millions d'euros pour aider les
universités et les opérateurs de
recherche à payer leurs factures
énergétique il contient aussi un nouveau
chèque énergie bienvenue qui cible les
ménages les plus modestes et des
avancées dues au travail parlementaires
preuve de son utilité 230 millions
d'aides pour les ménages qui utilisent
du bois domestique comme source de
chauffage le soutien la filière presse
et médias la dotation exceptionnelle
pour la Corse le soutien aux
agriculteurs victimes de la sécheresse
et l'aide à l'Ukraine ceci étant dit ce
projet de loi de finances rectificative
le ministre n'ayant pas écouté mes
compliments je vais faire les critiques
maintenant interroge également
notamment sur des prévisions de recettes
de TVA qui subissent selon vos dires une
moindre hausse et démontre une faille
dans une stratégie qui prévoit de
financer l'audiovisuel public et de
compenser la suppression de la CVAE au
collectivité par une fraction de TVA
les boucliers tarifaires sont utiles
pour penser les plaies face aux
multiples crises que nous traversons
mais ils sont inefficaces coûteux et
même inéquitables face à la bifurcation
écologique urgente et nécessaire une
illustration concrète la prolongation de
la remise de 30 centimes sur le litre
d'essence pour 15 jours 440 millions
d'après une étude du Conseil d'analyse
économique elle correspond à 18,50 €
d'aide mensuels pour les plus hauts des
cils et 9,50 € pour les plus bas des
cils bien sûr il faut fortement aider
l'aide à domicile qui va de villages en
village et travail dans sa voiture toute
la journée mais pourquoi subventionné
toujours plus c'est les ceux qui partent
en week-end en SUV par ailleurs pourquoi
faire porter cet effort au budget de
l'État seul quand les pétroliers
dégagent des profits indécents pire
encore cette mesure d'urgence va
l'encontre d'une autre urgence vit celle
là celle de réduire notre dépendance aux
énergies fossiles vous auriez pu
réserver l'aide à ceux qui n'ont pas le
choix et appliquez une mesure proposée
par la Convention citoyenne pour le
climat efficace immédiatement applicable
simple à mettre en œuvre peut coûteuse
pour l'État et bénéficiaire pour tous
les automobilistes bien que pas
nécessairement partagé par tous le
passage à 110 km heure
cibler et oui la lenteur est mérite une
éloge chers collègues ciblé monsieur le
ministre aidez ceux qui n'ont pas le
choix et appelez la contribution de ceux
qui accumulent dividendes et bien second
illustration la situation dans laquelle
sont placées les élus locaux vous
proposez et c'est une bonne chose un
amortisseur électricité qui permettra de
faire un peu mieux face son réserve que
ça ne fasse pas perdre le droit au
bouclier énergétique au détour d'un
système bien complexe comme Bercy en a
la spécialité mais vous placez les mers
et je prends cet exemple car nous sommes
nombreux à connaître cette
responsabilité dans cette émission dans
des situations intenables même ceux qui
dégagent de l'autofinancement et sont
donc de bons élèves ne savent plus par
quel bout prendre les augmentations de
fourniture de l'alimentation pour les
personnes âgées isolées les crèches les
enfants des cantines le chauffage des
équipements culturels ou sportifs ou
l'augmentation du point d'indice
pourtant bien
les mers aujourd'hui doivent prendre des
décisions qu'ils savent parfois injustes
voire contradictoires avec leurs
engagements pour le service public de
proximité ils le font avec courage et
sens des responsabilités et le
gouvernement les dénonce nous l'avons vu
tout à l'heure vous attaquez madame
Hidalgo mais des centaines de mer voir
des milliers devront augmenter leur taux
la DGF n'est pas une subvention c'est
une dotation pour service rendu
indexella sur l'inflation renoncer à la
suppression de la CVAE et imposer un
tarif réglementé de l'énergie pour
toutes les collectivités je présenterai
un des amendements en ce sens les élus
des collectivités sont assez
intelligents pour prévoir et décider en
responsabilité il faut leur donner la
possibilité de s'adapter face aux
décisions qui les frappent anticiper
s'adapter c'est ce qui est nécessaire
pour tous ne plus répondre à l'urgence
dans l'urgence encore moins par des
petits pas mais faire que chaque
décision ponctuelle porte en elle les
choix de la résilience durable à l'issue
de la COP 27 le président de la
République sera une fois encore d'eau au
mur agir plus fortement pour la
transition écologique et sociale le
saupoudrage les mesures ponctuelles ne
suffisent plus il faudra accélérer et
organiser la résilience de notre pays ce
PLFR hélas ne procède toujours pas de
cette logique
la parole est à Monsieur Didier Rambaud
pour le groupe qui Rassemblement
démocratique progressiste indépendant
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapport en général
monsieur le Président de la Commission
mes chers collègues au premier abord ce
second projet de loi de finance
rectificative et est un traditionnel
collectif de fin de gestion tenant
compte des crises survenues pendant
l'année les crédits sont ajustés en fin
d'exercices avec des ouvertures
compensées à hauteur de 5,4 milliards
d'euros plus de milliards pour France
compétences plus 500 millions pour le
ministère du travail au titre de
l'actualisation de la prévision sur les
compensations d'exonération de
cotisations sociales plus 1,1 milliard
pour les forces armées françaises en
raison du surcoût opérationnel dans le
contexte de guerre que nous connaissons
sans oublier les 450 millions prévus au
titre des mesures d'indemnisation
économique liées à la conjoncture ou
encore les 200 millions ouverts sur le
programme du ministère de la santé et de
la prévention permettant de financer
l'indemnité exceptionnelle versée aux
salariés auto-entrepreneur et
indépendant autant d'ajustements de
crédit nécessaire et bienvenue se passe
à l'ampleur de l'inflation et de
conséquences de la crise énergétique
néanmoins mes chers collègues ce projet
de loi de finance rectificatif
d'apparence traditionnelle n'en demeure
pas moins important et inédits
importants d'abord parce que ce texte
permet de financer des mesures d'urgence
historiques et la reconduction de
certaines d'entre elles avec pour
priorité de protéger nos concitoyens des
difficultés actuelles en raison de
l'inflation dans la continuité du paquet
pouvoir d'achat voter l'été dernier le
texte permet d'accompagner le chèque
énergie d'un versement de chèque
supplémentaire exceptionnel sans
condition de revenus d'un montant de 100
à 200 euros dont les premiers versements
sont prévus pour la fin de cette année
une mesure une mesure inédite mais
nécessaire pour de nombreux foyers dont
le coût se lève à hauteur de 1,4
milliards d'euros
ce second PFR finance également la
prolongation de la remise carburant à
hauteur de 460 millions d'euros alors
certes depuis hier la remise à la pompe
est dorénavant de 10 centimes mais je
tiens à rappeler deux choses d'une part
cette remise générale se poursuit
jusqu'à la fin de l'année et d'autre
part un dispositif mieux ciblé est
annoncé et en cours de préparation afin
d'aider en priorité les ménages les plus
modestes et celles et ceux que leur
surnom moral est gros rouleur mais ce
pdfr est également inédit en raison de
son adoption en première lecture à
l'Assemblée nationale dans le contexte
politique que nous connaissons tous ici
force est de constater que des
amendements provenant des multiples
bancs de l'opposition ont été adoptés à
l'image des 8 millions d'euros pour
aider les communes qui versent des
primes aux soignants des centres
municipaux de santé ou encore des 40
millions d'euros de crédit
supplémentaires en faveur des
associations d'aide alimentaire
la fin qu'elle puisse faire face à
l'augmentation du nombre de leur
bénéficiaires finalement ce P les faire
démontre ainsi que lorsqu'un dialogue
apaisé et constructif s'installe le
Parlement peut travailler sereinement
sur un texte budgétaire et l'adopter
même en l'absence de majorité absolue
nos collègues députés ont débuté avec un
état d'esprit constructif j'espère mes
chers collègues que notre assemblée en
fera tout en temps tout autant si ce
n'est davantage à ce propos notre groupe
mon groupe RDPI défendra deux
amendements un premier qui aménage le
filet de sécurité 2022 instauré cet été
lors du premier PFR pour le bloc
communal l'objectif est de prévenir ces
fameuses effets de seuil que nous
connaissons tous dans les communes en
ouvrant pour les communes dont la baisse
des parts brute et comprise entre 20 et
25% la compensation d'une fraction
réduite des dépenses d'approvisionnement
autrement dit ce premier amendement
complète le dispositif protestants qui
se déclenchait à partir du seuil de 25%
en ajoutant un second niveau de
compensation pour les communes moins
lourdement affectées par la hausse de
leur coût enfin le second amendement
élargit ce filet de sécurité 2022 pour y
inclure les communes qui sont engagées
dans un contrat de redressement en
outre-mer et qui ont engagé des efforts
afin d'améliorer leur capacité d'épargne
et que les critères existants pouvaient
exclure du bénéfice de la dotation bien
évidemment mon groupe ederpi votera sans
hésiter pour ce second PFR je vous
remercie
la parole est un monsieur Thierry cosy
que pour le groupe socialiste écologiste
et républicain
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous
examinons aujourd'hui le second PLFR de
cette année ce projet de loi n'est qu'un
exercice de fin de gestion qui permet
d'actualiser nos prévisions
macroéconomiques de corriger les
ouvertures de crédit et de prendre des
mesures d'urgence dont les faits est
immédiat ce texte se contente donc pour
sa majeure partie de prolonger ou
d'adapter des dispositifs d'aide
existants le temps de terminer
l'exercice 2022
avant de détailler les pointes
divergence qui lie notre groupe à ce PLF
de fin d'exercice je tiens à dire que
certaines aides prévues dans le texte
vont néanmoins dans le bon sens
je pense notamment à celle accordée aux
universités pour payer leurs factures
énergétique aux armées pour le carburant
aux agriculteurs pour faire face aux
conséquences des diverses qu'il
subissent
je note aussi le montant doublé des
moyens à louer à l'Ukraine pour de
l'équipement militaire le PLFR prévoyant
seulement un fond de 100 millions
d'euros nous plaçons ainsi comme le
douzième donateur l'Union européenne
cela n'était pas acceptable dans un
contexte international belligérant et au
lendemain d'événements en Pologne dont
on ne sait rien mais dont on imagine
tout il semble nécessaire de maintenir
un rapport de force suffisant avec
toujours pour seul objectif la recherche
de la paix mais revenons à la France car
quelques chiffres devraient nous
interpeller un Français sur 10 dépend de
l'aide alimentaire alors que dans le
même temps une personne sur cinq a froid
dans son logement et que 12 millions de
personnes subissent la précarité
énergétique
face à cela quelles réponses est
apportée il semblerait que le chèque
énergie dont on peut interroger le
caractère exceptionnel versé à 12
millions de foyers ainsi que l'Aristote
de 30 centimes qui tombent à 10 centimes
aujourd'hui par litre d'essence dans le
coup estimé à 440 millions d'euros ne
suffisent pas ou plus
car soyons aux honnêtes ces pansements
tiennent sur une jambe de bois et il ne
cache que trop mal votre absence de
vision quand on est nécessaire
déploiement d'une politique visant à
recouvrer notre souveraineté énergétique
et à effectuer la bifurcation écologique
inventée durant la COP 27 en Égypte
avec ses chèques vous traitez les
conséquences de cause que vous refusez à
voir vous réagissez mais n'agissez pas
contrairement à vos propos liminaires
monsieur le ministre si vous agissiez
vous auriez voté l'amendement socialiste
sollicitant une eau substantielle de 6
milliards d'euros afin d'engager les
travaux de rénovation énergétique que le
pays attend depuis plusieurs années et
ne me dites pas qu'augmenter
artificiellement le total des
financements ne déclencherait pas
automatiquement un déploiement des
rénovations énervées énergétiques
efficaces car soi-disant la filière ne
serait pas dimensionnée pour cela
depuis 2020 le président de la
République utilise cet argument pour
mieux justifier son inaction en la
matière mais le temps presse nous
comptabilisons plus de 7 millions de
passoires énergétiques en France je
rappelle que les relations énergétiques
ont deux vertus réduire la consommation
d'un logement en pleine crise des
énergies ce n'est pas superhétatoire et
c'est aussi excellent pour notre planète
qui multiplie les signes de fatigue je
souligne en ce sens le renforcement des
crédits alloués aux associations œuvrant
à l'aide alimentaire grâce au travail de
mes homologues socialistes à l'Assemblée
ce sont 40 millions d'euros
supplémentaires qui seront débloqués
afin de leur permettre de faire face à
la forte hausse des dépenses
énergétiques ainsi qu'à l'accroissement
du nom de leur bénéficiaire dans le
contexte actuel de crise qui je le
rappelle sont estimés entre 200 000 et
400 000 personnes supplémentaires
nous sommes bien conscients que tout
cela a un coût que nous n'ignorons pas
nous pensons même qu'il doit être
supporté par tous et dans le tout
j'inclus bien évidemment les profiteurs
de crise qui réalisent des supers
profits
ces profits sont pour une grande partie
le produit de rente il ne découlent en
rien d'un quelconque génie
entrepreneurial si souvent vantés pour
légitimer des salaires souvent
astronomiques pour certains dirigeants
nous pensons que cette contribution doit
permettre une juste répartition de la
richesse dans ce pays et nous veillerons
dans le débat sur le sur le budget 2023
que cette mesure d'équité économique
trouve une issue favorable enfin je note
une nouvelle fois que vous semblez
découvrir en fin d'exercice près de 5
milliards d'euros de recettes fiscales
supplémentaires j'entends votre volonté
que nous pourrions presque louer de ne
pas faire de projection de recettes trop
favorables en début d'exercice néanmoins
je suis dubitatif quant à l'écart ainsi
que la récurrence du procédé
à mon sens cela témoigne d'une volonté
d'user d'un artifice comptable pour
valoriser en fin d'exercice votre
prétendu bonne gestion afin de valider
de manière peu sincère vos théorie de la
baisse d'impôt permanente
pourtant les temps que nous traversons
nécessitent de la sincérité préalable
nécessaire à l'obtention de notre
confiance ce texte ne nous convainc pas
et c'est pour cela que le Groupe sert
s'abstiendra du fait de mesure trop peu
soucieuse de la justice fiscale
la parole est à la présidente du groupe
républicain du groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologiste
Eliana Zazie
[Applaudissements]
il y a républicain dans le nom du groupe
de la présidente Eliane assassin les
communistes
bon
madame madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues pour
débuter mon mon propos je vais emprunter
à Monsieur de Châteaubriand une de ces
fameuses Maxime je cite presque toujours
en politique le résultat est contraire à
la prévisions je trouve qu'elle résume
bien ce projet de loi marqué par des
modifications à la marge dans une
logique
d'atténuation des effets délétères de
l'inflation ces corrections sont les
carences je dirais même les erreurs
d'hier
c'est la dernière loi de finance
rectificative votée à l'été hier c'est
également la loi de finances initiale
vous n'avez pas interprété des signaux
économiques et sociaux vous n'avez pas
donc pas su anticiper il en résulte il
en résulte des dépenses en hausse de 70
milliards d'euros par rapport au budget
initial dont 3,8 engagé dans ce PLF et
non financier vous avez été aveugle à
l'inflation galop galopante dans le pays
que vous estimiez à 1,5% en décembre
2021 alors qu'elle culmine qu'elle
culmine à 5,3% aujourd'hui à l'été vous
continuez de la minorer de 0,3 points ce
n'est pas uniquement la guerre en
Ukraine vous le savez le bouclier
énergie avait été instauré avant ce
n'est pas uniquement les difficultés
d'approvisionnement vous le savez les
producteurs et les distributeurs avaient
déjà commencé à augmenter leur prix
l'inflation est de nature spéculative
laquelle a été aggravée par ces
phénomènes c'est dans ce sens là pas
l'inverse ces prévisions ont servi un
discours politique voulant faire croire
que les mesures à destination des
précaires et de nos fonctionnaires
étaient suffisantes les aides sociales
revalorisées de 4%, le point d'indice de
3,5 ces deux catégories de la population
ont perdu du pouvoir d'achat donc actes
les travailleurs du secteur privé ont
eux aussi vu fondre leurs revenus au
regard de l'inflation 2,2% de perte de
pouvoir d'achat en moyenne pour les
employés 2,7 pour les ouvriers 3,6 pour
les professions intermédiaires et des
cadres derrière cette moyenne les
ménages ne sont pas exposés de la même
façon face à l'augmentation de 11,2% des
produits alimentaires sur l'année ou à
celle de 19,6% des produits énergiques
le travail ne paie pas suffisamment dans
ce pays donc l'état Pali l'état
attendent de préserver un semblant de
cohésion sociale lorsque le travail ne
garantit pas les moyens de subsistance
c'est la nation qui se délite les tasses
donc
son chéquier étant d'alléger la facture
tout y passe l'électricité les pellets
de bois les carburants le fioul plus de
la moitié des crédits nouveaux ouverts
par ce PFR sont des palliatifs à
l'envoler indécent des prix de l'énergie
la politique d'échec c'est la politique
des faibles la présidence française de
l'Union européenne constituait une
opportunité de prendre des mesures
structurelles pour soulager les peuples
et les finances publiques blocage j'ai
pris sur les carburants notamment des
négociations serrées avec les
producteurs et principaux exportateurs
abrogations des directives de 1996 et
1998 de la libéralisation du marché de
l'énergie décoration des prix du gaz et
de l'électricité au lieu de cela les
finances publiques doivent assumer le
coût de ces mesures vous procédez pour
se faire à plus de 6,8 milliards
d'annulations de crédit et surtout vous
nous resservez le discours d'une
économie florissante comme en
attesterait la hausse de 32,8 milliards
de recettes fiscales par rapport à la
loi de finances initiale il n'y a pas de
trésor de guerre nous le disions par la
loi de règlement des comptes pour 2021
nous l'aurait affirmons les 19 milliards
d'euros d'impôts sur les sociétés sont
uniquement liées à l'augmentation des
profits stimulés par l'inflation
stimulée par l'absence du partage de la
valeur si l'économie se porte bien
pourquoi la croissance que vous
escomptiez à 4% au début de l'année
plafonne à 2,7 le discours autour du
partage de la valeur m'invite à
m'arrêter sur les 2 milliards d'euros à
louer dans ce texte à France compétences
je crois qu'il s'agit en vérité de
France patronat c'est 2 milliards
d'euros ont pour seul vocation de
subventionner l'emploi d'apprentis
considéré comme une main d'oeuvre bon
marché l'apprentissage à ces conditions
de rémunération n'est pas une aubaine
pour la France c'est une aubaine pour le
patronat payé en dessous du SMIC
lorsqu'ils ont moins de 26 ans sur
lesquels les entreprises récupèrent un
véritable pactole 5000 euros pour les
mineurs 8000 euros pour les majeurs
faisant baisser artificiellement et
conjoncturellement les chiffres de
l'emploi 50% des apprentis environ ne
conservent pas leur poste à l'issue de
leur cursus pour être remplacé par
d'autres laborieux la cohérence est de
votre côté il s'agit d'une armée de
réserve du patronage cher au ministre
d'armanin les étrangers appelés à la
rescousse les apprentis appelés au
service votre vision de la politique en
faveur de l'emploi doit enfin être au
service des créateurs de la valeur au
service donc des travailleurs si nous
soutiendrons certaines mesures prises
dans ce PLFR comme l'aide aux
associations d'aide alimentaire ou les
modestes 8 millions d'euros pour les
oublier du Ségur des centres municipaux
de santé les carences sont trop
importantes à cause de cette absence de
vision économique et budgétaire à cause
de l'absence de volonté de remédier
structurellement aux mots provoqués par
le libéralisme si ce n'est par la
politique d'échec nous ne signerons pas
en bas de la feuille monsieur le
ministre on ne signe pas un contrat
lorsqu'il est défavorable aux intérêts
des plus élémentaires de la population
nous voterons contre et nous nous
donnons rendez-vous demain pour l'examen
du projet de loi de finances
Vincent apocanellas pour le groupe Union
centriste vous avez la parole
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre monsieur président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général qui va nous rejoindre
mes chers collègues nous sommes saisis
dans ce second projet de loi de finance
rectificatif pour l'année 2022 comme il
est d'usage enfin d'année pour
régulariser les crédits ouverts en
fonction des prévisions plus proches de
l'exécution réelle mais c'est toutefois
théoriquement le dernier de ce type à
partir de 2023 en raison des nouvelles
règles établies par la LOLF que nous
avons révisé monsieur le Président en
202122 non 21 pardon nous dévatrons de
loi de finance de fin de gestion
spécifique en juillet dernier le premier
PLSR 2022 a apporté un soutien de 44
milliards d'euros supplémentaires dont
20 milliards consacré à la protection du
pouvoir d'achat le texte présenté
aujourd'hui s'inscrit dans le
prolongement de ce paquet pouvoir
d'achat avec une rallonge de 2 milliards
5 c'est bienvenue bien que cela
s'inscrit dans un contexte budgétaire
dégradé
la prolongation jusqu'à la mi-novembre
de la ristourne de 30 centimes par litre
puis de 10 centimes est aussi inscrite
le tout pour une enveloppe de 440
millions d'euros quand même le groupe UC
salue aussi le fond de 275 millions à
débloqué par le gouvernement pour aider
les universités établissements de
recherche et les CROUS pour les aider
donc à faire face à la hausse des prix
de l'énergie
dans la même logique le PLFR ouvre des
crédits pour couvrir les frais de
carburant exceptionnel du ministère des
armées à hauteur de 200 millions d'euros
et de 1,5 100 milliards d'euros pour la
mission défense ceci afin de financer le
soutien militaire que nous apportons à
l'Ukraine vous permettrait à cette
occasion au nom de l'ensemble des
sénateurs centristes de salut
l'engagement de nos soldats dans le
monde au service du pays et de la paix
le combat contre la vie chère selon la
formule que vous avez employée tout à
l'heure monsieur le ministre ce combat
est bien sûr confronté à la réalité de
nos finances et nous devons à la fois
resserrer notre politique budgétaire
faire face aux difficultés de nos
compatriotes les accompagner et éviter
de casser la croissance c'est un
équilibre difficile auquel on essaye
tous c'est un réglage complexe et nous
avons en tête ces contraintes qui
relèvent parfois d'injonctions
contradictoires
en même temps ces dépenses s'ils avaient
été affectés à l'équipement de nos
compatriotes en véhicules moins
énergivores ou à la rénovation thermique
des logements aurait permis des progrès
plus durables c'est le dilemme devant
lequel nous nous trouvons faire face aux
réalités du moment et construire
l'avenir en même temps et c'est un
moment il faudra basculer peut-être sur
des mesures plus durables mais il
fallait faire face je ne peux m'empêcher
de souligner que 8 milliards le montant
de l'aristo voulait appeler tout à
l'heure monsieur le ministre ça aurait
permis quand même pas mal de primes pour
un million de foyers et de prime durable
il faudra qu'on y réfléchisse la
situation de l'économie française en
cette fin 2022 et certains certaines
mais moins défavorable que celle
d'autres pays et nous vivons cet
enchaînement de crise sanitaire
l'énergie la guerre en Ukraine et en
Europe à notre économie résiste mais
nous avons la préoccupation de savoir
combien de temps elle pourra tenir à ce
rythme-là et nous entendons évidemment
les avis du Haut conseil sur ce sujet
un point d'alerte quand même sur ce PLFR
les créations de poste c'est une un
sujet de préoccupation dans l'immédiat
ce budget de fin de gestion vient
ajuster les mesures utiles pour nos
compatriotes et correspond à des
constats de fin de gestion le groupe
sont tristes votre à la quasi unanimité
ce second budget rectificatif tel que
modifié par le Sénat il portera
évidemment des amendements sur le filet
de sécurité pour les collectivités en
matière énergétique et sur la
répartition de la taxe d'aménagement
comme sur le FC TVA je vous remercie
merci la parole est maintenant madame
Isabelle briquet pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur général monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues monsieur
le ministre ainsi que vous avez eu
l'occasion de le rappeler lors de la
présentation de ce PLF ce texte traduit
des choix qui n'ont pas varié en effet
si ce texte prévoit et c'est heureux un
certain nombre d'être ponctuelles j'y
reviendrai il témoigne aussi du dogme
idéologique de la baisse de l'impôt et
de la réduction de la dépense publique
si la maîtrise de nos comptes publics
est nécessaire comme le souligne le Haut
Conseil des finances publiques disposées
de marges de manœuvre suffisantes pour
faire face au choc macroéconomique et
aux besoins d'investissement public ne
peut se résumer à cette approche
purement libérale dont on mesure bien
les limites et les dangers
singulièrement pour les plus modestes de
nos concitoyens
dans un contexte de crise multiple vous
avez fait le choix de verser des aides
de moins en moins exceptionnel tout de
même pour soutenir le portefeuille des
ménages
à défaut de politique structurelles ce
texte contient plusieurs mesures
ponctuelles dont il convient de prendre
acte favorablement face à l'urgence et
aux difficultés de nos concitoyens
certains dispositifs sont d'ailleurs
issus des débats parlementaires à
l'Assemblée nationale comme par exemple
les 40 millions d'euros de crédit pour
les associations d'aide alimentaire et
quand on connaît leur fonctionnement on
sait qu'ils seront plus que nécessaire
nous saluons également l'intégration
dans ce texte d'un amendement que nous
avions présenté au Sénat lors du PLFR
examiner cet été qui consiste à allouer
des aides supplémentaires à
l'enseignement supérieur et à la
recherche pour permettre aux universités
de faire face à la hausse du coût de
l'énergie et donc permettre aux
étudiants de poursuivre leurs études
dans des conditions acceptables
la nouvelle mouture d'échec énergie et
l'aide à l'achat de carburant même
réduite ne peuvent que contribuer à
l'allègement des charges qui pèse de
plus en plus lourdement sur les ménages
pour autant est-ce là une réponse
politique à la baisse du pouvoir d'achat
des Français
dès demain la discussion du PLF pour
2023 sera l'occasion de débattre sur le
fond des réponses à apporter pour
s'attaquer réellement aux inégalités
sociales et revenir sur un modèle de
redistribution des richesses
à l'heure où la France compte 12
millions de personnes vivant sous le
seuil de pauvreté les mesures
gouvernementales sont les bienvenus mais
elles ne saurai vous exonérées de
proposer des solutions pérennes pour
permettre à nos concitoyens de vivre
dignement
pour ce faire il est nécessaire d'en
terminer avec le désarmement fiscal et
conserver des recettes à la hauteur des
enjeux
en cette fin d'exercice nous constatons
cette année encore des recettes fiscales
supplémentaires à hauteur de 4,6
milliards soit approximativement le
rendement de l'ISF si les prudent de ne
pas faire de projection de recettes trop
favorables en début d'exercice et si
l'on peut remarquer cette année que
cette louable prudence s'est avérée un
peu plus modérée qu'à la coutumée ce
supplément de recette ne saurait trouver
sa justification dans la baisse du taux
de prélèvement obligatoire comme
l'avance le gouvernement une baisse
d'impôts est une baisse d'impôt quelle
que soit la manière dont on analyse les
choses ce sont bien des recettes en
moins dans les caisses de l'État et ce
sont forcément des recettes en moins
pour le financement des politiques
publiques et des services publics
nous prenons donc acte monsieur le
ministre des mesures d'urgence portées
par ce texte et nous poursuivrons nos
débats dans les jours qui viennent avec
la discussion du projet de loi de
finances pour 2023 merci enfin dernier
orateur inscrit dans cette discussion
générale monsieur Jean-Marie maison pour
le groupe Union centriste
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances monsieur le rapporteur
général mes chers collègues en août
dernier alors que nous examinions
l'examen du premier projet de loi de
finances rectificatif pour 2022 je
m'étais inquiétés devant vous du
syndrome de largeur magique et d'un quoi
qu'il en coûte qui est en dépourvu de
bornes étaient dépourvu de sagesse
depuis les taux d'intérêt qui étaient
restés négatifs et à peu près stable
depuis 2019 non cessé de poursuivre leur
remontée sauf retournement la prévision
gouvernementale pour la fin de l'année
2022 à 2,5% à d'ores et déjà été
dépassés puisque le taux moyen de l'eau
at à 10 ans au mois de septembre dernier
a atteint 2,7%
. pour rappel ce même taux était de
1,6% des buts et de 2,2% fin juin pour
rappel également d'après les estimations
de la Banque de France chaque hausse
d'un point des taux d'intérêt entraîne à
l'issue d'une période de 10 ans un coup
annuel supplémentaire de 40 milliards
d'euros pour le budget de l'État soit
l'équivalent du budget actuel de la
défense
mes chers collègues la politique
inconsidérée de dépenses publiques qui a
permis hier de financer sous anesthésie
la Banque centrale européenne aura des
conséquences très réelles dont nous ne
mesurons pas encore concrètement tous
les effets négatifs quant à notre
déclassement économique
l'été dernier à l'issue de l'examen du
texte à l'Assemblée nationale le déficit
budgétaire de l'État tutoyé les 180
milliards d'euros en hausse de près de
25 milliards d'euros par rapport à la
loi de finances initiale le second
collectif budgétaire que nous en
transmis une collègue députée affiche du
fait d'un très grand nombre de crédits
reportés un solde qui s'améliore de plus
de 5 milliards d'euros nous pourrions
certes nous en réjouir de déficit
budgétaire de l'État qui vient en
laisser alimenter une dette publique
elle-même vertigineuse reste cependant
assez nettement supérieur à 170
milliards d'euros par égard pour les
générations futures ne peut s'en
satisfaire vraiment nos collègues notre
collègue Vincent kapoucanellas a rappelé
l'essentiel de ces mesures que justifie
la protection de nos compatriotes face
aux dangers que sont l'inflation élevée
la guerre en Ukraine et les aléas
climatiques beaucoup d'entre elles sont
ciblées sur les publics les plus
fragiles par souci d'équité autant que
de maîtrise des comptes publics
le groupe Union centriste qui en appelle
depuis le début de la crise à des
mesures qui soient le plus justement
calibré sans réjouit
mais ne nous cachons pas derrière notre
petit doigt
nous ne pourrons pas éternellement
dépenser sans compter et faire
l'économie de réforme d'envergure
trouver de nouvelles et pérennes sources
d'économie afin de réduire
significativement notre déficit et notre
endettement public
commanderait d'engager son délai
d'importantes réforme structurelles mise
en oeuvre de d'une réforme des retraites
plus ambitieuse que celle annoncée par
le président de la République réformes
des prestations sociales et de
l'assurance chômage réorganisation et
redéfinition du périmètre de certains
services publics tels ceux de
l'enseignement scolaire ou de
l'audiovisuel avec à la clé une baisse
tangible des effectifs report et même
dans certains cas annulation des
augmentations de crédit prévus dans le
champ des politiques publiques non
régaliennes etc etc plus tardif seront
des efforts plus brutal encore sera
notre réveil je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci la discussion générale est close
et nous passons donc maintenant à
l'examen des articles nous avons à un
amendement numéro 62 monsieur le
ministre
oui merci madame la Présidente c'est un
amendement qui met à jour les prévisions
sous-jacent